welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler and i am
the special
temporary primary host on an ongoing
basis and joining me today is greg
knuckles he is kermit currently at least
for
for the time being the permanent guest
co-host for now
uh greg thank you for joining me thanks
for having me on uh before we get into
the content today i want to start by
thanking everyone who subscribed during
our big mass anniversary sale we really
appreciate the support there so welcome
to all of our new subscribers
if you missed out i have great news you
can still subscribe it's just not a sale
anymore
uh but if you want to support the show
in other ways there are a lot of
different strong pitch work
there are other ways you can support the
show
you can like rate or subscribe wherever
you get podcasts
you could go to strongerbyscience.com
newsletter and join our email newsletter
list
you can go to bulksupplements.com and
use our discount code sbs pod that will
get you a five percent discount the
stock market is roaring so take those
five percent uh
gains and put it all in the market that
seems to be going super well today uh ma
again mass research review is one way
that you could support us by subscribing
or you could chuck out
macro factor that is the diet app that
we created uh that is subscription based
but you can try a free trial just to see
if you like it
uh road to the stage how's it going greg
road to the stage yeah so uh once again
this week not much to report um
so
and there's a reason for that so i
i've talked about this on the podcast
before
i do
for many years i consumed virtually no
fiber in my diet
beyond fruit um it
consistently gives me uh well you know
okay so
most of the fiber sources that i opted
for tended to cause a fair bit of gi
distress like if if i would just have a
lot of cruciferous vegetables or
especially a lot of beans
i don't know why but that [ __ ] would
just [ __ ] me up uh i would feel like
trash not even like gassy i would just
feel like i would just feel like i was
dying like i would feel like a bloated
corpse um so anyway
i've had a very low fiber diet for a
long time
uh but i decided like you know what
let's try to find a source of fiber that
agrees with me because you know there
are plenty of benefits of of having more
fiber in your diet
so i hit upon something that
a food item that i used to consume a
fair bit just completely forgot about it
for a few years but this road to the
stage segment comes with a
recommendation which is to check out
just grains that you can cook and eat
the same way you would rice so for
example for example like bulgur wheat uh
frica
uh pearled barley
so
you know it's basically just like the
the berries of various sweets or grains
um
you know the husk is still intact the
fiber is still there and yeah you just
submerge it in water boil it cook it the
same way you would like rice for example
um but it's great uh it hasn't been
affecting me the same way that
cruciferous vegetables and beans do
which is a plus
um and also like it tastes nice so i
when it comes to my bread habits i'm a
child i despise whole wheat bread i
don't despise it i'm i'm overstating
things but i don't like it uh you know i
i prefer just a nice white bread i don't
like the taste of whole wheat bread
but for whatever reason the taste of
whole grains when you just
uh cook them and eat them as grains i
find so much more pleasant it might just
be a textural thing um but like texture
wise i think i i even prefer them to
rice because
like they
like there there's more texture there i
guess like there's a little bit more
resistance to your to your tooth when
you uh when you bite through them uh
nice nutty flavor like the the flavor
notes that people talk about with whole
wheat bread that they talk about in a
nice way
i don't like them in whole wheat bread
for whatever reason but when it's just
like isolated in a single cooked grain i
find it very nice
but anyway as this relates to the road
to the stage segment uh something that
you see pretty consistently in the
research is that when people either go
from a low fiber to a high fiber diet or
a high fiber to a low fiber diet there's
generally like a
like maybe one one and a half percent
shift in body weight one way or the
other just because
you know you now have more fiber in your
system more intestinal contents
basically um
i'm full of [ __ ] exactly yeah uh full of
[ __ ] but like in a in a way that's
in general good for your gi health um
so anyway i i fully anticipated my
weight to go up uh two or three pounds
when i started eating a lot more fiber
it did and within a week it's already
back down to about what it was before so
i think in real terms like my
my total uh
uh net metabolizable energy stored in my
body is probably down about a pound this
week number on the scale is about the
same i'm attributing that to the fiber
uh but uh yeah if you don't
so if you're struggling to get more
fiber in your diet you don't like eating
a ton of beans you don't like eating a
ton of vegetables you know maybe you eat
a lot of rice maybe eat a lot of
potatoes maybe you're just looking for
some other carb source to try uh find
some bulgur find some pearl barley find
some freakah there there are several
others as well uh but they're great a
lot of fiber tastes good would highly
recommend
so you and i are a little bit different
in terms of diet and nutrition uh i
don't know if you ever heard about this
but
after one of my competitive uh
bodybuilding seasons i was trying to
like kind of ease my way back up to my
my kind of typical walk around weight
which was going to involve considerable
weight gain but i was trying to you know
just kind of make it a slow steady
process so i was like how am i going to
find foods to eat that will facilitate
this because i was ravenously hungry
and so i would go to work every day i
would take a a one gallon ziploc bag
and stuff it and i i mean like i would
have to squeeze it to zip it shut
stuff it with just raw uncooked broccoli
yeah that's [ __ ] up um
and then i would take a second one
gallon ziploc bag and fill it
to its capacity with raw carrot
and so i i could do raw carrots yeah
that's fine that was i got fewer looks
for that and this isn't this is by the
way not a recommendation i was young and
i was just trying to find things that i
would that i could feel like i was
eating all day and not gain like 75
pounds in the first three weeks
um but anyway i got a lot of looks for
that and honestly
i enjoyed it very much uh i don't know
if i would go back to it but
yeah the the cruciferous vegetables and
just kind of
snacking on raw uncooked vegetables all
day
never a problem for me have i told do
you remember if i've told my my raw
cabbage story on the podcast yeah yeah
uh
if i i think if i went that route i
would literally die
probably so
uh all right so road to athens uh no
running yet um as i mentioned previously
uh i'm about 0 for nine going through
the kind of standard
route of medical care uh
but jason you're uh the physical
therapist at stronger by science on our
coaching staff
literally is a wizard and a magician so
in about three messages he figured out
what was wrong with me um i'm kind of
easing my way into implementing some of
those tips
but for now no running yet
but i've been having a really good time
just kind of rediscovering my enthusiasm
for exercise in general now that i'm
exercising
a little more regularly and getting my
hip moving in different ways
i'm a terrible swimmer which is actually
great because i've been doing swimming
workouts
and
man my caloric expenditure is through
the roof just because like
if you suck at swimming swimming is
just a bottomless pit of calorie
expenditure like i'm flailing in every
possible direction except moving forward
so it's been a great it's been great for
working out not great if i were to like
fall off a boat in open water
um but anyway i've been enjoying my
swimming workouts um
playing more basketball working on the
left hand
dribbling getting some left-hand layups
and even some some mid-range jumpers up
with the left hand trying to really
build it up so in the near future i'm
going to be getting onto the court and
getting competitive and it's going to be
something to see
but for now just kind of building up
skills and getting moving
and just generally strengthening my
abdominal musculature and the
musculature surrounding the hip and yeah
so far so good uh now feats of strength
greg what do you got this week yeah so
i've got one and i've also got a little
segment behind it so uh
last episode talked about kristoff we're
bicky hitting the third biggest deadlift
of all time in training
he pulled 490 kilos
raw with straps in the gym
which at the time was the third biggest
deadlift ever done and before that
episode came out uh he he obsoleted that
prior pr
and he pulled five hundred and two and a
half kilos which is eleven hundred and
eight pounds it's not by a little bit
that's a yeah it's an enormous job
twelve and a half kilo pr
um
and yeah i mean you can watch the video
it'll be linked in the show notes it's a
it's a rock solid deadlift like it looks
great uh not gonna litigate the straps
versus no straps if you want our
opinions on that listen to the feats of
strength segment in the last episode
um but yeah super impressive stuff and
that is
to my knowledge and i think to
everyone's knowledge uh the heaviest
deadlift anyone has ever done uh like
you know with with any sort of
qualifiers you want to put on it
it's the most weight that was at one
point on the floor that someone in one
fluid motion uh lifted off the ground to
lock out uh insanely impressive stuff
and you know like we mentioned last
episode uh the other the only other
members of the 500 kilogram club are
eddie hall and thor who were
big old boys when they pulled those
those weights and weirbiki uh is around
105 kilos like 230 which is
a big old boy by just like normal
standards but is
a kind of typical average size boy by by
powerlifting standards and certainly
much smaller than than eddie and thor so
insanely impressive
and
so that begs the question uh
you know what's what's going on here so
there's a current a current hot topic in
the fitness world and that is is sumo
deadlifting cheating uh the
i think flash point for this
was uh uh
elite natural or not natural uh classic
classic bodybuilding classic physique
what there's so many bodybuilding
divisions which which one does bumstead
compete in
he has a nice physique
that's the extent of my knowledge i
think it's classic bodybuilding that
sounds right okay uh not natural
misspoke there classic bodybuilding um
so yeah uh he's
i think he's won the last two or three
olympias in that division uh great
physique um
and yeah he he recently said i think on
like an instagram live stream or q a
that sumo deadlift was cheating uh and
jeff nippard recently put out a
in-depth video responding to that claim
discussing whether or not sumo
deadlifting is cheating
we'll link jeff's video in the show
notes i think that he did a really good
job
rebutting the claim that sumo
deadlifting is cheating
we'll also link a stronger by science
article in the show notes that goes over
many of the same points
uh but yeah so
um
this this is something that people are
talking about and i i am in the camp
that sumo deadlifting is not cheating
but
when people see christoph weir bicky
pull
a heavier deadlift at 230 than
super heavyweight strongmen have pulled
at 400 plus it makes people wonder like
okay like this
this this is clearly
you know it's more weight at a way
lighter body weight he has to be getting
a huge advantage from pulling sumo right
um
and so
you know you can look at the research
and say
uh
both research and just competitive
results and say on average it doesn't
seem like there's much of a difference
between sumo and conventional deadlift
you know it's not it's not something
where like everyone's going to pull way
more weight sumo than they do
conventional they're not just
fundamentally different exercises
and you can say that and you can cite
research and like i said if if you
hear me saying this and you have a
knee-jerk response like oh no like that
that has to be wrong like they have to
use
completely different musculature very
different lifts uh check out the
stronger by science article check out
jeff's video i i don't feel like
re-litigating all of that on the podcast
but i do want to
address the very understandable
observation
that you know there are some people uh
some really good sumo deadlifters and
you look at what they pull sumo and
you're like
there are no conventional deadlifters
within the same zip code like where
bicky he competes at 231 like i said
uh pulling 1100 off the ground in
training there are no conventional
deadlifters in that weight class who are
close to that number um
so you know that
very understandably makes people think
like you know regardless of what the
science says there has to be something
going on here
that is allowing people to get some sort
of huge advantage from the sumo deadlift
and i think that
they're actually correct in that
observation
but that doesn't
discount the fact that on average there
doesn't seem to be that much of a
difference so
uh
basically what i want what i want to
talk about here
is the
difference i guess between
between averages
and uh
you know kind of the the breadth of a
distribution and how that can
present itself for outliers so
essentially
my perspective on this
is that you know some people are going
to do better with sumo some people are
going to do better with conventional on
a population level the differences
between the two probably aren't
particularly large
but
there are definitely some people who
seem to get a huge advantage from the
sumo deadlift and the reason i think
that is
is
the different strength curves between
the two exercises
so
for
not all but most sumo deadlifters the
hardest part of the lift is right off
the floor so if you can break the bar
off the floor and not have to sacrifice
all of your positioning to do so
you can lock it out like basically once
that bar starts moving if if you're if
you don't already find yourself in a
horrendous position
you're going to be able to lock it out
whereas that's not the strength curve
for
conventional deadlifts so for
conventional deadlifts the weakest part
of the lift tends to be somewhere in the
general mid-shin area um so you can look
at this uh in in studies that like
report
like velocity time curves so the point
of peak deceleration
in a
conventional deadlift that you grind is
generally like two or three inches off
the floor so you're not
some people are but most people aren't
the very very weakest off the floor in a
conventional deadlift like there are
generally weights that you can break
from the floor
that you can't get past your knee and
lockout so you're dealing with slightly
different strength curves there
and so essentially
what i think is going on
is that for
some people who both have the hip
structure
for sumo deadlifts to really agree with
them
and who also have really great leverages
for sumo deadlifting and by that i
mostly just mean really long arms uh
they can essentially cut out a large
enough portion of the really really weak
part of the range of motion that kind of
in practical terms they're sort of doing
a partial if that makes sense and sumo
deadlift is such like the strength curve
as such
that if you can kind of get in that
position where you're doing a pseudo
partial it can pay huge huge dividends
whereas that's not the case so much with
conventional deadlift and you can kind
of test this for yourself so
if you're someone who has
a decent bit of experience with both
sumo and conventional deadlift what you
can do is just go to the gym and just do
a like a three inch block pull one rep
max and compare that to your maxes from
the floor so
just speaking for me personally
so i have i have really short arms it's
very unfortunate uh
eric just mentioned basketball i play a
lot of basketball long arms big wingspan
good for basketball i don't have them
can't clog up passing lanes the way i'd
like to it's unfortunate also affects my
deadlift uh
and so um yeah like my
conventional deadlift my
my best pull from the floor
is 7 735 and my best pull from from
three and like three or four inch blocks
is like 740 so
um and and that's basically because like
you know my weakest point in the
deadlift is basically where a three or
four inch block pull is starting so i'm
gonna have to go through that range of
motion with a pull from the floor i'm
gonna start at that part of the range of
motion for a three four inch block pull
so ultimately it doesn't make that much
of a difference if i do like a six-inch
block pull like still below the knees
i'm i am going to be able to pull more
weight but it's still not like a huge
night and day difference but then once i
get above my knee you know i can pull
way way more weight
for sumo on the other hand
and
unfortunately i don't have video of this
you're just gonna have to trust me uh my
best deadlift from the floor sumo is
what is it it's either 705 or 725. i
don't do sumo and meat so i don't pay
that close of attention but it's
somewhere in the low sevens
i've pulled 850 from a four inch block
uh or 855 from a four inch block sumo so
we're talking an enormous difference and
so if i was someone
whose arms just happened to be four
inches longer which wouldn't be freaky
outlier proportions like that would that
would if anything give me more normal
proportions
i would have a huge advantage pulling
sumo
and i essentially think that's basically
what's going on so if someone has the
hips for sumo which i do
and they also have relatively long arms
so they can get
in a starting position that would be
equivalent to a
starting position of a low block pull
for someone with shorter arms
they're they're cutting off a relatively
large portion of the range of motion
that would otherwise be the hardest part
of the range of motion
and you just don't get that same dynamic
with the conventional deadlift and so
essentially what i'm proposing is that
for
the vast majority of individuals like 95
plus of people
you don't have to worry about that like
that dynamic isn't in play uh you know
sumo will feel better for some people
conventional will feel better for some
people uh
i think largely just based on hip
structure but i think if you
are one of the people who has hips that
are well suited to sumo and who also has
kind of outlier body proportions to
allow allow your setup from the floor to
be comparable to a low block pull setup
for another person
i do think that that that for
for that small minority of lifters can
net them a pretty big advantage in the
sumo deadlift and so
you know then that begs the question the
framing device for this segment is sumo
cheating and i would say
no absolutely not uh i mean ultimately
the point so one you know you can just
look at the rules like in powerlifting
is sumo allowed yes okay cool it's not
cheating uh and then two on average does
it seem to be
way way easier than conventional for
most people no not really
uh but then it's like okay for a small
minority of people it does seem to give
a pretty big advantage where if those
same people with really great body
proportions for conventional that or
just great body proportions for dead
lifting in general like if you have
those proportions it's going to help you
for both sumo and conventional but it
might help a little bit more for sumo
than it does for conventional
and so then that begs the question like
okay well is is it cheating or in some
way unfair that they get a bigger boost
from sumo uh than than they would
conventional uh due to their outlier
body proportions
and like
i think that just kind of depends on
your conception of fairness
um
like i i fundamentally think it's fine
like those people have access to an
advantage that most people don't have
access to but ultimately that's just the
name of the game in elite sports like uh
every every sport on the planet at a
high level is basically just like hey
everyone's playing by the same rules uh
and
who has the physiology that allows them
to best take advantage of those rules
and you know for for the for the very
very freaky sumo deadlifters out there
you know i i think they just hit the
lottery and i think it is what it is and
that's fine and it's it that's not just
like a weird quirk of sumo being allowed
in powerlifting that's like how it works
for everything so
you know like uh
nba playoffs are going on right now and
you look at giannis's absolute wizardry
around around the rim like he's so tall
his arms are so long he's so [ __ ]
quick he's so explosive and he has an
insane touch around the basket uh and so
you know scores a ton of points in the
paint with crazy efficiency and he can
penetrate into the paint way better than
most people because he can take such
long strides change direction so well
and he's so quick
that gives him a huge tangible advantage
compared to virtually everyone he plays
against
but no one would say that's cheating
it's just like oh well giannis won the
genetic lottery for basketball and uh
yeah i think christoph wierbicki won the
genetic lottery for deadlifting uh
and that's fine um
so yeah i i think i think that there are
individuals who
do get a huge boost in performance from
having access to sumo uh that
other people
aren't like other people aren't going to
have access to that advantage just
because they they don't have the build
for it um
but i fundamentally think that's fine
and i don't think that on average sumo
gives the sort of advantage that would
lead one to classify it as cheating
yeah i mean like you said when you start
looking at uh high achievers in any
remotely athletic contest um
you know you you look at the highest
level performers
and almost always you can start to
identify ways that they were kind of
built for what they do um and and that's
kind of to be expected when there's a
a large pool of potential competitors
and so like yeah i mean
watch the olympics
you know every four years and they'll
say hey we're gonna do a little segment
about why michael phelps is built to be
a swimmer
and why uh
uh bolt is is built to be a sprinter you
know and and or like kipchoge being
built for the mirror built to be a
marathoner yeah in almost every instance
you can start to look at these
characteristics that are advantageous
for the sport and what do you know the
high achievers happen to have them i i
remember hearing a story i was going i
was at a physiology lecture and they
were talking about outliers in various
physiological capacities and they were
talking about a mountain climber back in
the day i forget his name but he's you
know kind of a renowned uh like one of
the greats of all time
and apparently early in his mountain
climbing career he was mostly confused
he would go on climbs with groups of
people and he would keep going and going
and going and he'd be like
why is everyone slowing down uh you guys
don't seem like you can breathe is every
like what is happening here uh and only
later did they start to recognize that
he was
truly an outlier in terms of uh the way
he was able to handle oxygen at altitude
you know he had physiological
characteristics that made him just a
completely different breed when it came
to mountain climbing so yeah i i don't
um
i don't think it makes sense to kind of
take that approach and say well oh just
because someone has advantages for a
sport that's unfair uh if anything that
seems to be the rule for sport rather
than the exception you know high-level
competitors
generally are are are really optimized
for what they do and some of that is uh
just the luck of the draw you know and
and yeah like you said uh
you know if you're convinced that if
you're a power lifter and you're upset
that people are are cheating by doing
sumo just do sumo you know it if it were
really that
uh
that much of an advantage across the
board then you just wouldn't find
conventional deadlifters or you wouldn't
find many of them yeah but yeah oh and
and one more thing i'll note as well um
so this is something that jeff mentioned
in his video that i i don't think he
really went in depth uh explaining but
one thing that you do see in
powerlifting that that makes all the
sense in the world through
the lens that i'm using to frame this
this segment we're basically like if
you're built in such a way that sumo
lets you cut off a large enough portion
of the bottom part of the lift largely
just due to how you're built you may get
a huge boost from it so through that
lens uh one thing that you can observe
is that the sumo deadlift is quite a bit
more popular than the conventional
deadlift for shorter lifters so
lightweight males and lightweight and
middleweight females and then the
conventional deadlift is quite a bit
more popular
in the heavier weight classes for both
sexes and is super popular for the super
heavyweight class for male lifters
because supers tend to be pretty tall um
and so
i think what explains that
is that the
the range of motion for a deadlift is
very arbitrary so you know it's always
determined by the radius of the plates
that determines how high off the ground
the bar is and so it's starting higher
relative to the shin for shorter lifters
and lower relative to the shin for
taller lifters and so if you're a short
lifter who also happens to have long
arms or even if you don't have long arms
it's just relatively a shorter range of
motion because you're a short person and
and the bar is starting higher on your
shin whereas for taller people even if
you do have relatively long arms and a
conventionally good build for deadlift
the range of motion relatively speaking
is just longer because the bar is
starting relatively lower uh and so i i
think that's basically what's going on
like if if you have long arms and you
also happen to be short and you also
happen to have hips that can let you
adduct a lot um
you know you you might very well have a
100 200 or if you're very strong like
300 pound difference between your sumo
and conventional deadlift where you can
pull more sumo um
yeah i think that's just kind of
a quirk of the lift whereas if it's the
opposite set of circumstances where uh
and like so
the the kind of test i mentioned you
could do before of just comparing your
sumo and conventional deadlifts from the
floor versus a three four inch block
pull you can do that opposite
test with a deficit deadlift and what
many people will find is that if you
do a sumo deadlift from like a three
inch deficit your numbers are going to
go way way down whereas if you do a
conventional deadlift from a three-inch
deficit
your numbers probably won't be that
different from the floor like you'll
you'll probably pull a little bit less
but not necessarily a night and day
difference
so yeah like i think that's that's
basically what's going on where if
someone has relatively short arms uh
especially combined with being a
relatively tall person sumo gives them a
pretty big disadvantage because it's
it's just not compatible with how
they're built and kind of relatively
speaking it would be like a shorter
person with longer arms pulling a
deficit sumo deadlift um
so yeah like i i think that's one of the
big factors uh and i don't think we're
bicky himself
is particularly short he just has really
long arms uh and he can he can abduct
super well um
yeah so i i think that that uh explains
the the trend observed in lifters of
sumo being more popular with shorter
lifters conventional being more popular
with taller lifters i i think it's just
owing to the fact that that range of
motion itself is is fairly arbitrary and
the radius of the plates kind of happens
to be
in that nether realm where
for some people
uh it is going to result in sumo giving
a relatively large advantage and for
some people conventional giving
a relatively large advantage over sumo
uh if if people wanted to make that
completely fair where it's just like hey
we're gonna take
uh like
the the relative height effect out of it
and completely
um
you know do away with
the sumo or just the deadlift in general
starting relatively higher on the shins
for shorter people lower for taller
people what they could do is just have
the bar start on the floor where you
know like the
the plates are kind of
underground almost and then there's a
little kind of like gap where you can
like get your hands around the bar but
just the bar is starting at floor height
and it's floor height for everyone
that would kind of level the playing
field
and
uh i think i think under those
circumstances most people would pull
conventional
and also
most people would pull with enormous
spinal flexion that would be that would
be fun to see as an experiment to really
test the hypothesis of is spinal flexion
dangerous i i think if powerlifting
shifted over to that style of deadlift
for a year we
we could have a pretty decent estimate
um
but yeah i mean that that's just another
thing to note powerlifting overall uh
both uh
deadlift and also bench press there are
advantages of being a short power lifter
so already talked about deadlift it's
starting relatively higher on your shins
might increase the odds that you can get
a pretty big boost from being able to
deadlift sumo another advantage that
short power lifters have is just that uh
like you can go relatively wider on the
bench press uh and we've talked about
this before too where
when when people get upset about the
really really short ranges of motion for
competitive power lifters it's almost
always the lighter weight lifters
there's a reason for that lighter
lifters tend to be shorter lifters
shorter lifters tend to have shorter
arms and the maximum bench press width
is 81 centimeters for everyone so if
you're five foot two and you're benching
with an 81 centimeter grip width like
your arms are almost completely out to
your sides to start with uh whereas if
someone's 6'4 with long arms if they go
81 centimeters like
that's still kind of a moderate grip
bench press um so yeah like
being short gives you access
uh sometimes like depending on muscle
insertions how you're built more
generally but kind of on average it
gives you access to
certain techniques that taller lifters
just don't have access to um but yeah i
mean that like that's that's just how
how the sport is like that's that's how
it works
all right good stuff so i think i'm
gonna answer a few q a questions uh and
then we'll
we'll jump back to your uh article
discussion after that cool
so uh i'm gonna jump in here with some
uh questions from listeners
so first of all nice quick easy one
i had a question from arjan arjon
and the question was considering the
road to enlightenment is there a
vegetarian variation of the culinary
shredded chicken staple
so basically back in the day when i was
an omnivore
i would cook a bunch of shredded chicken
in bulk and i would leave it pretty
pretty plain and that way throughout the
week i could utilize it for a variety of
different types of dishes you know i
could have more of like an italian kind
of theme or a mexican kind of you know i
could do tacos with it whatever i wanted
to do i could kind of build around that
basic protein source
um you know one of my big protein
sources currently is uh chickpea curry
um which is really nice but it doesn't
have a lot of versatility it kind of you
know there's a lot of really bold
flavors in it a lot of seasoning so you
know that curry is going to taste like
that curry no matter what so it is a
staple in my diet but it's not that same
kind of interchangeable protein source
like i had with the shredded chicken
i think the closest thing i have right
now would be cubed tofu and so what i'll
do is i'll cube up tofu into little you
know little squares
and i will
cook them in the oven i'll basically
coat them in a mixture of soy sauce and
corn starch
doing soy sauce alone without the corn
starch not advisable the corn starch is
really nice because it allows it to
crisp up which is really nice for the
texture and it just kind of retains a
little bit more of the flavor like the
soy sauce flavor i think
so i'll put that in the oven um and just
do a huge bulk preparation of a bunch of
cubed tofu with soy sauce and cornstarch
and that's about as close as i've gotten
where uh you know pretty much any savory
dish if you know if i wanted to have
like uh i could probably use them in
tacos if i wanted to i can put them into
any kind of soup that i've made and they
work pretty well um but yeah i've
noticed that the cube tofu it's also
great for stir fries if you're just
looking to kind of put something
together really quick
but in terms of
vegetarian alternatives that's that's
probably my best approximation that i
have currently
uh next question from rj francisco
he mentioned that uh he or she i'm not
sure mentioned that uh
they loved the talk about structuring
goals so we had an article about that
and a pretty
long podcast segment as well
and the question is about whether or not
i have any insight about procrastination
so this individual is going back to
school needs some help
with procrastination and also mentioned
this might be a helpful topic for people
who
kind of put off going to the gym and
potentially even skip the gym because
they keep putting it off and delaying
and things like that so
i definitely wouldn't claim to be a
subject matter expert on procrastination
but i have gotten more and more into
some psychology research uh in recent
months so i i did skim some literature
so that i could answer this in a fairly
evidence-based manner not purely just
going on anecdote so uh first of all the
kind of defining procrastination i found
a pretty good definition for it which is
the voluntary delay of an intended and
necessary uh or important activity
despite expecting potential negative
consequences that outweigh the positive
consequences of the delay
uh so the primary factors here are
you're delaying an activity that you
know you should be doing and one of the
kind of defining characteristics is that
when you make the decision to delay
doing this you consciously know that
this is not in your best interest you
know that they're going to be
ramifications for it and so for that
reason when you look at some of the
literature on procrastination they'll
mention it as an irrational behavior and
that's irrational in kind of the
textbook sense you know if you're
talking with someone not a good idea to
tell them that they're being irrational
that's a good way to really uh
have an unpleasant conversation that
escalates from there but what they mean
by irrational is
you are making a decision that is not
rational in nature in the sense that
you know that this is not in your best
interest but you are still delaying that
activity
but one thing that's important to keep
in mind with procrastination is that in
my experience it is more of a behavior
than a totally stable
and universal personality trait and so
what i mean by that is some people might
be more susceptible than others to
procrastination but
even within the individual you'll
probably tend to find that it is uh a
bit task specific and context specific
so
you know you might uh
procrastinate more than others but there
are probably certain uh contexts in
which you procrastinate more or certain
tasks that you tend to procrastinate
more
so so i try to mention that so that
people don't think this just boils down
to you know hey there's people with will
power and there's people without and if
you procrastinate a lot you know that
reflects really negatively on you as a
person i think it's important to realize
that there is some specificity in terms
of uh when we
elect to procrastinate and so given that
procrastination is not in our best
interest
one might ask why do we do it in the
first place um you know why would we do
something that is not ultimately
the best choice for us and part of it
has to do with a term called temporal
discounting
so we generally
um
psychologically
we tend to
we tend to really favor short-term
outcomes at the expense of long-term
outcomes so like when it comes to
procrastination temporal discounting
puts us in a situation where we say
i know that there are negative quant
consequences for this out in the future
but i also know that there is a
short-term reward for delaying this
thing i don't want to do and temporal
discounting refers to the fact that we
will take that short-term reward even
though
you know we'll have more value for that
reward in the short term even though we
know that there's usually an even bigger
downside coming down the line but since
it's far away we don't seem to worry
about it as much when we're making that
decision so temporal discounting is just
that mismatch in terms of how we value
things in the short term versus how we
value things in the long term yeah yeah
but i know that what i'm doing right now
is gonna happen but something that
happens down the road who knows if i'll
even still be around for that like i i
somewhat frequently procrastinate
getting in bed at night i might die in
the night and i and i either will or i
won't there's two options there's a 50
50 shot that i'm gonna be dead in the
morning yeah um
so i mean like yeah i think it's
perfectly rational to procrastinate
because i know that i'm guaranteed
the moment that i'm currently in that
that is a good point i haven't seen that
raised in any of the literature that i
that i perused well that's that's a
pretty big oversight yeah but but the
general idea there is that the reward of
doing something more enjoyable now
outweighs the knowledge that we know
we're going to be paying for it later so
that's part of it another part that i
think is important to consider when
you're asking why you're procrastinating
is
what are the characteristics of this
particular task that are making you not
want to do it so uh of course there's
just a general aversion to certain
unpleasant activities perhaps you have
some anxiety about the activity or
anxiety about the fact that you know you
can't mess up this activity you know
it's it's very important and so maybe
you have some anxiousness about what
would happen if you messed up or maybe
you have a lack of self-efficacy for
that task maybe you don't trust in your
ability to do it well and so for that
reason you're less likely to engage with
it or you have more desire to delay it
until you absolutely must do it
it could be that you just lack intrinsic
motivation for the behavior
generally speaking intrinsic motivation
seems to be much more powerful than
extrinsic sources of motivation so if
you don't see this as something that is
uh driven by intrinsic motivation if you
don't see this as genuinely being a
worthwhile task or something that is
good for you personally if you're just
doing it because someone said you have
to
that makes it much more likely
that you will procrastinate
and then just generally speaking if you
are spending time
ruminating over
you know instances in the past where you
didn't enjoy this activity or it went
poorly or if again you're having
anxiousness about the future
consequences of doing this activity
poorly those can all kind of contribute
to procrastination so
in terms of useful strategies i think
one thing that helps is
you know approaching a task with
curiosity if you can find a way to do
that that usually helps me
kind of
embrace doing something if like if i'm
kind of dreading writing something you
know if i know i need to do an article
sometimes it'll help if i say if i
approach it with more curiosity and say
what might i learn in the process of
putting this article together you know
sometimes that curiosity
is enough to get me moving in the right
direction um sometimes i need to find a
way to support my own sense of intrinsic
motivation so
when i'm trying to find intrinsic
motivation i think a lot about
self-determination theory you know am i
am i doing this task in a way that i
have all of the sufficient competence
relatedness and autonomy to really make
me feel excited about doing it and
ultimately competent enough to do it
well
and if not then sometimes you start to
notice hey i keep procrastinating this
kind of cluster of tasks and what can i
do so that as i'm doing those i feel
like i have more autonomy over how i do
it or i feel more relatedness in terms
of the the way i'm approaching it uh or
or i just feel more competent doing this
task
um i think in some cases mindfulness and
acceptance based interventions can be
helpful so just thinking through the
fact that like listen this needs to get
to get done
building up acceptance for that and
thinking through uh you know just kind
of coming back to the present moment
trying to get rid of all the anxiety
over the future rumination over the past
and say i know this has to get done and
if i sit down and calm down and think my
way through it mindfully i will
recognize that
it only serves to
you know it only works to my detriment
if i continue to put this off so if you
can kind of build up that accept
acceptance for the task use some
mindfulness get back to the present
moment stop having anxiousness about you
know doing the task and disliking the
task and what happens if you mess up the
task just come back to the present
moment think through it calm down a
little bit accept the fact that this
will get done eventually and you'll kind
of work toward more of an understanding
that doing it now is probably the best
choice for you rather than delaying it
but i think one of the most important
things we can target is something they
call onset delay
so researchers looking into into
procrastination often find that one of
the key things that
promotes continued procrastination one
of the the real hallmarks of pr
procrastination isn't that people start
doing it and then say actually screw
that i'm gonna do something else it's
that they never actually start it's
delaying the onset of the activity not
doing a little and then leaving and then
doing a little then leaving
so what you want to do is target that
onset delay and i think that there are
some really creative ways that you can
do that so for example
the person asking the question mentioned
if you're procrastinating for the gym
what can you do
something that i've actually done in the
past which
isn't like a perfect example but it's
something i have done
is if i'm like you know what i'm
dreading going to the gym i don't really
feel like it
in the past i would sometimes just drink
my pre-workout
and i would say okay
i
am now hyper-caffeinated
so if i don't go to the gym what's the
point of being this caffeinated uh i've
now invested a dollar fifty into this
workout because i had my dose of
pre-workout or whatever they cost these
days i don't know but you know you you
start to say okay i have started the
process of getting it to the gym i've
already made this kind of upfront
initial investment and this cascade of
events that leads from me sitting here
to getting to the gym has already begun
the onset has happened because i've
taken the pre-workout which leads to
getting in the car which leads to going
to the gym which leads to the workout so
if you can find a an interesting way to
kind of break that inertia to get the
process rolling and to target onset
delay i think that's one of the more
interesting ways to uh to kind of push
back against an urge to procrastinate so
an example
if i'm kind of dreading doing a reading
assignment or writing something one of
the things that i'll do is get my
workspace ready for me to do it right so
i might go make some tea i might clear
off my desk get out the book that i'm
going to be referencing the most when
i'm writing get the document loaded and
ready to go just setting the stage to
begin and what you'll find is that just
by doing these preparatory uh tasks you
are initiating that cascade of events to
get you actually doing the thing that
you are currently procrastinating uh so
that would be my kind of quick look at
procrastination and some potential ways
to overcome it whether those
whether you're procrastinating something
that's fitness related or something
completely unrelated
a couple other quick ones and then i'm
going to throw to you for your article
review oh i can can i just toss in an
anecdote for that last one sure yeah so
yeah i i habitually uh procrastinate on
writing stuff uh or at least i have
previously and for the last couple of
months something that's been helping me
a lot is is very similar to what you
were just describing and one of the
things that i've noticed about myself is
that
my willpower to do things i don't want
to do wanes pretty quickly throughout
the day and so um
basically like my work day used to be
oriented completely differently where
like all of just the general emails and
messages and [ __ ] i had to respond to
i'd take care of that first and be like
okay now i have a block of time to do
good writing high value stuff for the
business uh and there's nothing else
hanging over me and like in theory i
thought that should have worked but
uh oftentimes i would get to that point
in the day and just be like [ __ ] i don't
want to do any of this [ __ ] like it's
hard
some of those things you mentioned
before like
you know this is important stuff so like
if i if i mess it up like there's going
to be consequences like whatever so um
yeah i did that for years and it uh you
know i still did what i needed to but it
was uh
not the smoothest process most of the
time
so something i've done
that that has been helping me a lot is
uh i'll i'll try to set the stage for
the next day basically at the end of my
work day so
once i get done with so now i do the
important stuff first and then uh
respond to my emails messages stuff like
that
closer to the end of the workday
and then what i do at the very very end
of the workday
is whatever the most important thing i
need to get done the next day is i just
go ahead and get all of that stuff
pulled up on my computer before i turn
like before i power it down for the
night
and if if i'm going to be doing stuff
online like i do all of my writing in
google docs
i have like a website blocker where
i restrict access to every website
that's not google docs and so
uh you know when i get on my computer
the next day studies i'm going to be
referencing are already pulled up i
pulled them up the night before
the document that i need to work on is
already pulled up and
if i try to type in another website my
browser will block me and say you can't
do that and so if i wanted to
procrastinate i would need to
go through the step with friction of
manually disabling the website blocker
and just kind of like committing to
myself like yeah you're going to be a
piece of [ __ ] today like you're you're
intentionally not starting on the thing
that you had determined you should have
started on um so yeah i'm removing
friction that is between me and the
thing i need to get done and i'm adding
friction between me
and the other things that i would
generally do to procrastinate and kill
time um
and yeah i would say that that has had
probably like a 80 success rate like
there are definitely still some days
where i'm like nope nope
i'm tired i'm not starting on writing i
don't feel like it i'm going to do some
other stuff and those work days tend to
just be a waste of time and i look back
at the end i'm like [ __ ]
i should have started with writing uh
but yeah like like eighty percent of the
time that that tends to go pretty well
and it's it's been helping a lot
yeah i've done the same exact things
where um
it'll be closer to the end of the day
and maybe i'm doing a collaboration
where i'm gonna run stats for somebody
and i'll be like i am not in the mental
space to do this because you know it's
you know
research they make it impossible to do
corrections you know it's like a
one-year process filled with shame
uh you know correcting research should
be a lot easier than it is but it's not
so when you're doing stats there's the
anxiousness of like you have one shot
here and if you put something dumb in
your line of code you're going to mess
up the whole thing it's going to be bad
so like sometimes i'll be like all right
i'm not really in the mental state where
i can go through this whole thing for
three hours and be perfect and efficient
so i'll do kind of what you mentioned
i'll get my
software up i'll load the data set into
the software i'll take care of those
preliminary steps i'll bring up some
resources if i need them i'll get to
everything except showtime
and then i'll shut it work day is over
i'll come back in the morning and i'll
know everything's ready to go time to
start you got to be sharp for the next
you know two hours when you're doing
this analysis but but yeah it's it's
kind of a way to just set the stage and
say i'm going to come back to this and
it's going to be the first thing i do
with pure focus you know
all right so i do want to answer uh two
more questions really quickly here so
one is from kim
and kim asks if you have to lose a lot
of weight would you break the cut into
bits of 12 weeks with some maintenance
periods in between or would you do it in
one big cut
um
12 weeks
is the magic number that's going around
on the internet
um
i have not seen strong evidence to
support this number i i think basically
somebody kind of used it as the number
that felt good to them
and then it just kind of propagated and
kind of went everywhere wasn't 12 weeks
uh what they did in the matador study
no
oh all right
uh no so matador was uh two weeks on two
weeks off repeated oh okay yeah so the
the 12-week number i i think it was
somebody's just kind of basic guideline
that they're like ah that should be good
and it just got really popular uh i've
never really seen strong research to
support that 12-week number but
nonetheless whatever you think that
number should be
i don't
i i reject the premise of just having a
set number um there
may be benefits of doing diet breaks
whether they are physiological or
psychological or just simply practical
right sometimes you get about 18 weeks
into a diet and you say you know what
next week is vacation i don't feel like
being on a diet on vacation so looks
like a diet break or maybe you say you
know what i've been dieting on and off
for 42 weeks and the holidays are coming
up i know i'm gonna have some meals so
maybe for the next six weeks i kind of
shift into maintenance mode you know
there are a number of justifiable
reasons to incorporate diet breaks or to
press pause for extended periods of time
during a cut but i don't i cannot think
of a particular number of weeks that
would be universally advisable i think
it really comes down to
you where you're at in the diet if you
feel like physiologically you just need
a break from dieting that's a great
reason to take a diet break if
psychologically you feel like you need a
break again that's a great reason to
take a diet breaker to shift to
maintenance for a while
if life events require that you kind of
take your foot off the gas pedal again
totally advisable time to take a diet
break
but i only take diet breaks when
i need them you know so if things are
going really smoothly and i'm at 11 and
a half weeks into my diet and i say oh
no the 12-week threshold is coming that
means absolutely nothing to me i'll keep
going until i feel like i want or need a
diet break and physiologically i've just
never seen any reason to put a set limit
on the number of weeks that you can
continue with a sustainable diet
and if your diet cannot be continued
sustainably then you probably want to
take a break shift to maintenance and
during that maintenance phase think
through how can i formulate potentially
a more sustainable approach when i get
things back moving so uh i i don't see
any reason to hold yourself to a set
limit in terms of how long you can
maintain a diet it should be more how
you're doing physiologically how you're
doing psychologically and just what life
is throwing at you at that particular
time
now a somewhat related question
is from ola
and ola asks is there a need for a
maintenance period after a bulk to make
sure that the mass stays on
so this is looking instead of saying hey
do i need maintenance phases during cuts
this is after a bulk do i need a
maintenance phase to kind of solidify
that new muscle tissue before i can you
know transition into the next fat loss
phase or cut
my answer would be no
um
this is a common recommendation and i
wouldn't be shocked if i've potentially
suggested something along these lines in
the past you know way back
but after you know putting a lot of
thought into it i think this is probably
just an illusion
that is popular because it's a
common and generalizable illusion so at
the end of a bulk we're often kind of
watery and bloated and we're all beefed
up uh we're usually like pretty overfed
um so we're in a position where we are
really
at an inflated body weight just due to
water weight and gi content and things
of that nature uh and in many cases our
total daily energy expenditure is also a
bit inflated as well just because in the
context of overfeeding sometimes we do
have an adaptive process where we up
regulate our our total daily energy
expenditure so we're in a kind of unique
state at the end of a pretty serious
bulk where we're pushing the food intake
pretty hard um now sometimes people will
shift
straight from that state where they're
bulking into a cut
and it'll have a huge drop in calories
there will be a huge initial drop in
scale weight
you know your carb and sodium intake go
down uh maybe glycogen shifts a little
bit drop in water weight less gi content
because you're going from over feeding
to under feeding and a lot of people see
that initial drop in scale weight and
they say wow i just lost a tremendous
amount of muscle in reality that has
nothing to do with muscle loss
and and muscle loss in that scenario is
pretty unlikely if you're if you're
putting together your diet effectively
um
and another thing that that kind of
contributes to that is
a lot of people do have a tendency
myself included back in the day to
overestimate muscularity during a bulk
uh i remember
thinking i was just putting on pure
muscle until a roommate was like dude
you've you've gained a tremendous amount
of fat and i i think someone needed to
tell you and no one would yeah uh but
it's a impromptu intervention yeah i was
totally certain that all the weight i
was gaining was muscle and he was like
yeah it's
maybe 15
uh so so that actually is really common
though like if you talk to someone who's
who's been bulking and just kind of
recreationally bodybuilding and you say
how many pounds do you need to lose
before you're going to be shredded
a lot of times they'll say 20 when the
number's 40. like when we bulk we have a
tendency
uh because you know things are going
well the scale's moving we're getting
stronger sometimes we have a tendency to
overestimate the amount of muscle we're
putting on and to underestimate how much
fat would need to be lost to get to a
particular physique that we have in mind
and so i think that there's a
compounding effect there
where people they do that initial abrupt
change from a bulk to a cut body weight
drops really quickly and they think i
think i just lost a lot of muscle
and they decided on the front end i'm
going to lose 20 pounds in this cut they
lose their 20 pounds they aren't as
shredded as they thought they would be
and they said you know what happened i
lost all that muscle the first couple
weeks that's why i'm not as shredded as
i thought i would be 20 pounds lighter
so i think there are a couple different
types of illusions that are kind of
contributing to this idea that you need
to do maintenance to kind of solidify
that muscle before you transition to a
cut but at the end of the day i cannot
think of a single physiological reason
that you would have to take that
approach i can't think of a mechanistic
explanation of why that would be
necessary but i can think of a couple
practical reasons why someone might
prefer that so first of all like i said
it can
it can be
quite a drop when you go from fairly
aggressive over feeding to fairly
aggressive underfeeding
and so if you wanted to have kind of a
smoother more predictable transition at
the beginning of your cut just in terms
of scale weight it might make sense to
go from over feeding at the end of your
bulk to a little maintenance let things
kind of settle see exactly where you're
at in terms of body weight and then
initiate the cut you might just get some
smoother transitions in terms of scale
weight that aren't quite as jarring
and another practical benefit would be
like i said sometimes with over feeding
during a bulk we will see that total
daily energy expenditure is not just
high but inflated you know there's an
adaptive increase and so you might want
to you might consider it to be very
practical and helpful
to drop down to maintenance
and kind of see where your cat calories
settle there
uh and then use that number to inform
your first calorie drop when you
transition to a cut so there might be
some practical benefits that make the
process a little bit more predictable um
but but in terms of physiological
benefits i truly can't think of any uh
so so it's it's a viable option but i i
don't consider it to be a
a requirement or something that is
necessary yeah i think it's uh
i think it's basically the the inverse
of something we've talked about before
like when
when someone gets really shredded for a
bodybuilding show and then they come out
of it they start overfeeding and they
think like man i'm building so much
muscle right now this is incredible uh i
got super lean so my insulin sensitivity
is really good right now and through
some physiological process that i can't
exactly sketch out for you i'm sure that
that is resulting in tremendous
hypertrophy i think it's basically the
inverse of this where yeah you know like
you're already so lean you're gonna have
to gain quite a bit of fat before you're
gonna start seeing like really really
big visual changes and also like you're
you're seeing relatively small visual
changes in terms of fat accumulation but
the scale goes up 10 pounds because like
hey you weren't eating before now you
are replenish all of your glycogen you
have some more gi contents everything
just kind of fills back out and you're
like [ __ ] man i just put on
12 pounds of muscle in the past month
when like you didn't uh and so i think
that this is the same thing but just in
reverse yeah i think that's a very very
appropriate analogy there
uh all right so greg before we wrap up
the show um
we would love to hear about your newest
article featured on stronger by science
yeah absolutely so
um you know who
would you like to hear talk about
uh
hormonal contraceptives for female
lifters
two dudes absolutely that's what many
people are saying so so that's what
we're gonna do
um yeah i know so i i recently had an
article uh on stronger by science called
do oral contraceptives affect your gains
and uh yeah so it was looking at this
question uh it was nominally a review of
a study by oxfelt and colleagues called
molecular markers of skeletal muscle
hypertrophy following 10 weeks of
resistance training in oral
contraceptive users and non-users um see
it was nominally a review of that study
but mostly i just wanted to
just broadly review the literature
looking at the impact of hormonal
contraceptives on strength and
hypertrophy outcomes in female lifters
because i think this is a topic where
there
at least seems to be a fair bit of
misinformation and a fair bit of
scare-mongering fake news fake news yeah
um and i think that
i mean i think a lot of it just kind of
goes back to
just some version of the naturalistic
fallacy where or an appeal to nature
where
you know um
you just kind of assume that if you're
putting synthetic hormones into your
body uh since that's not natural
something bad must happen uh and uh
maybe it's gonna kill your gains like
whatever um
like i i think that's kind of the kernel
of the of the line of reasoning that
leads
a lot of influencers on social media to
just
flatly recommend that uh women in their
audience not use hormonal contraceptives
you know they they say it's going to
make it harder to build muscle
attain positive training adaptations
and
the thing is like that was
maybe a tenable position
five years ago because there just wasn't
that much research on it
and you know with with anything it's not
that hard to find negative anecdotes
about
virtually anything that someone could do
so there's not that much research
there's plenty of negative anecdotes and
you're like well okay like
maybe this isn't a good idea uh but
within the last five years or so there
have been quite a few studies looking
like you know studying in a controlled
way
the impact of
uh oral hormonal contraceptives on
strength hypertrophy outcomes and
they just find that it it doesn't really
seem to matter uh it doesn't seem to
make much of a difference so at this
point there have been 10 papers
published from eight discrete studies
comparing strength lean mass hypertrophy
outcomes in users and non-users of oral
contraceptives undergoing the same
resistance training program
and
by and large they find really no
meaningful difference and if you're if
you're the type of person who
more enjoys a
liberal interpretation of research
results we're like i don't care about
statistical significance i don't
necessarily need to see a meta-analysis
that that confirms that within this body
of literature one thing or the other is
better if you're someone who more just
you know wants wants to look and see
where the wind is blowing like is this
inconclusive body of literature leaning
in one direction or the other uh
if at this point it is leaning in one
direction or the other it's actually
leaning in the direction of
oral contraceptives maybe improving
hypertrophy outcomes i and i'm not
making that as like a strong claim like
they will definitely help you build more
muscle
i i personally think it doesn't make any
material difference
but if if the literature is leaning one
way or the other
that seems to be the way that it's
leaning right now
and like i said at this point it's not
just based on
just one isolated study or one or two
papers like there's you know there's 10
papers in this area which
you know
as with most things in our field i would
love to see a larger body of research on
this you know like 30 papers are better
than 10
but 10 is a lot better than than for a
lot of questions uh in our area and
they're painting like this body of of
literature is painting a pretty cohesive
picture like you
you can look at the results of these
studies there's a table uh linked in the
stronger by science article that you can
check out
let's see it is table
table 5 in the article
that that just breaks down all of the
results of these studies and uh yeah if
if
oral contraceptives do negatively impact
your gains
it has not been observed in the
literature to this point
um see i i don't
really feel like i need to go super
in-depth about the oxfail paper uh
in particular
but i i did just want to note that like
if if someone does want to claim that
oral contraceptives
negatively affect strength and
hypertrophy outcomes
just know that whatever they're using to
make that claim
isn't based on actual longitudinal human
evidence because the longitudinal human
evidence does not support
fear and trepidation around oral
contraceptives
negatively affecting hypertrophy or
strength outcomes
however there are two things to note
about this body of literature
one and and this this is very important
um
and this is something that
uh i haven't seen discussed for
like
all that much among kind of the
skeptical audience like people who share
my perspective that oral contraceptives
are probably fine for strength
hypertrophy outcomes
there's a major drawback in the
literature that i don't see
those people who i broadly agree with
mentioning very often and that is the
potential for selection bias
so
these studies are
longitudinal human studies high quality
evidence but the highest quality
evidence from intervention studies would
be a randomized control trial so
you recruit a group of subjects you
randomly assign half of them to one
intervention randomly assign half of
them to another intervention ideally you
blind people so they don't know which
which
arm of the study they're in they don't
know which intervention they're getting
maybe it's the active treatment maybe
it's the placebo and then you see at the
end you know did this treatment have an
effect that that is the gold standard
and
uh oral contraception studies and female
lifters
by and large aren't rcts um you know and
i there are there are good ethical
reasons for that like
and just practical reasons you know if
if you go into a college and you're like
hey we want to study oral contraceptives
uh
you know they have these effects they
might have these risks like whatever
like these are discussions you generally
have with your doctor but you know half
of you
we're just gonna put you on birth
control the other half of you we're
gonna give you placebos and we're gonna
see how that affects hypertrophy um
i don't think that many people would
sign up for that study so
the way these studies tend to work is
you just put out a call and you're like
hey we're doing a strength and
hypertrophy study come to the lab we'll
screen you like get you in if you meet
our inclusion criteria and so they'll
recruit subjects who are already using
hormonal contraceptives and subjects who
aren't currently using hormonal
contraceptives so like it's not an rct
and so there might be the potential for
selection bias where
it is possible for
the research to exist as it is and all
of it be correct and very well done and
also have a blind spot where it could be
that for
you know some
fraction of women maybe even some
relatively large fraction of women
hormonal contraceptives have negative
effects and one of those effects would
be hindering strength and hypertrophy
however that might also be associated
with other negative effects that would
lead women to discontinue using hormonal
contraception in the first place
so i don't know if that is the case but
but that's kind of the point we don't
know if that's the case or not like that
is
a blind spot in the literature um
and another potential blind spot well
this isn't even potential one definite
blind spot in the literature is that uh
there are a lot of forms of hormonal
contraception that exist that that women
have access to
and
virtually all of the research looking at
the impact of hormonal contraceptives on
strength and hypertrophy outcomes use
second and third generation combined
hormonal oral contraception so
there are four broad generations of of
oral contraceptives uh and i don't know
maybe the fifth is brewing these days
who's to say i i haven't followed that
super closely but uh most of the
research is just on the second and third
generation pills
there's not any research that i'm aware
of on fourth generation pills and then
there are
things beyond combined oral
contraceptives so combined oral
contraceptives contain
uh either estrogen or some sort of
estrogen analog and some form of
progestin
so that's the combined it's both
estrogen and progestins
but then there are also progestin only
contraceptives so the the mini pill if
you've heard of that that's just a
progestin only oral contraceptive that's
never been tested uh like its effects on
strength and hypertrophy there are uh
progestin only injections they have
never been tested for their effects on
strength and hypertrophy uh like i said
fourth generation combination pills
haven't been tested uh hormonal iuds
haven't been tested intravaginal inserts
haven't been tested
and a lot of those things are growing in
popularity like go back
like 10 years ago and
the the majority of hormonal
contraception used were just second and
third generation combination pills
but especially in recent years iuds and
intravaginal inserts have gotten a lot
more popular and their impact on
strength and hypertrophy outcomes hasn't
been assessed at this point
i'm not aware of a good a priori reason
to suspect that they would have effects
that would be
way different from second and third
generation oral contraceptives uh but
they might and and they haven't been
assessed so
uh the literature as it exists now
is like if you want to be
you know if you want to go by the book
and not extrapolate and just say like
okay what has the research actually
looked at and let's not extrapolate
beyond that it's just looking at second
and third generation combination pills
um so yeah there's there are still some
blind spots in terms of
other popular forms of hormonal
contraception whose impacts on strength
and hypertrophy haven't been assessed
yet um
so yeah with with that caveat uh
fully discussed and with the potential
selection bias noted um just to
reiterate based on the literature that
does currently exist
it doesn't appear that second and third
generation combination pills
have
really any meaningful impact positive or
negative on strength and hypertrophy
outcomes
yeah i thought it was really interesting
you mentioned that you were not making
the claim that oral contraceptives these
hormonal contraceptives enhance gains
but you actually don't edit the podcast
and so only on thursday
will you find out exactly what points
you did or did not make so we'll see how
creative i can get with the editing uh
but for for all the listeners if you
want to hear the points that greg has
already submitted in writing uh be sure
to check out that article for all the
details and we will link that article
in the show notes
now greg you are
our
temporary senior
uh
media correspondent and pop culture
correspondent so what do you have this
week to play us out
yeah just to circle back to the last
podcast i gave a tentative
recommendation
for the apple tv series slow horses
which is a a british
i guess crime detective drama thriller
type deal
um
and i said i had watched all of the
episodes that were out up to that point
but the finale had not aired yet so i
gave it a tentative recommendation and
said that i still needed to see if it
would stick the landing and i
report with great joy that it did the
finale was great and uh i was very
surprised to see this i assume season
two is coming soon they kind of kind of
gave a look ahead of like oh what to
expect in season two there was a [ __ ]
ton of footage i think they've shot the
whole thing or if not they're they're
very close to it um
and i don't know like a lot of
a lot of british shows like man the the
british entertainment industry they they
don't do the us thing like the the us
approach to tv shows is just like find
something that's marketable it's going
to put enough enough butts in the seats
that you can sell ad space and then just
just run it until the wheels fall off
and everyone loses interest um but you
know like like basically find a
marketable franchise and just stick with
it as long as possible and if you can
get two or three spin-offs out of it
even better the brits i think this makes
for for better
entertainment products overall they make
art yeah like uh they they tend to you
know
do more limited series or stuff that
like ah we're gonna do a season and then
who knows maybe we'll do season two five
years from now
we'll see um
so yeah i was watching slow horses just
assuming that it was a limited series
and uh it wasn't until
after the finale aired and they started
showing stuff from season two that i was
like oh [ __ ] there's gonna be more uh
and if it was an american show i
definitely would have anticipated that
there would be more but uh
since it's british i just assumed that
there wasn't so i was i was pleasantly
surprised to see that as well so
uh if you like slow horses if you check
it out um there it seems like more is to
come and uh in my book that's a good
thing
yeah i mean i think probably the best
example of the discrepancy there is um
with the office
yeah uh
it is a great example because we have a
uk version and an american version
the uk version uh unless i'm mistaken i
believe they had two epi uh two seasons
with six episodes each and then like a
two-part christmas special i believe
that was the extent of the uh the uk
office cannon uh and then they revisited
uh with like kind of an updated
documentary type uh project
somewhat recently
the american office did i think 37
seasons and everyone i know
when i when i asked someone hey did you
watch the office the question is when
did you give up
you know what i mean like oh yeah i know
a lot of people who got oh i got six
seasons in or seven in i don't remember
exactly how many they did but yeah it
was just a completely different approach
to how television works yeah yeah um but
anyway cool yeah i
it's funny you mentioned the idea of
sticking the landing with a season or
with a show
um
i was uh driving back on saturday night
uh from your place to my place
my girlfriend and i were driving back
and we had a conversation that we've had
30 times before
um and it was just lamenting the ending
of of two different shows like because i
only watch like
over a decade's time i may only get to
eight shows
you know what i mean it's very funny
like we
so
audience here's here's a fun bit of
history about mine and eric's friendship
one of the first things we bonded over
and and like the the main thing that we
started doing to hang out outside of the
lab outside of a work context was you
would come over to watch game of thrones
every sunday and and that was
where we started hanging out just on a
more regular basis and so uh there was
that then there was westworld like you
you were early on like my tv buddy like
a dude who was fun to watch tv and drink
beer with
and then i come to find out you don't
watch any tv no those are two of the
like six shows that i've watched over
the last several years
um but no the funny thing is the the
whole car ride home we were talking
about how just absolutely terrible the
end of game of thrones was
um and then you know how disgruntled i
am about the trajectory that westworld
is on uh i thought the first two seasons
were incredible the third i absolutely
hated and the fourth i'm a little bit
concerned about uh but yeah it's always
nice when a show uh is able whether
you're talking about within a season or
within the entire series when you're
able to wrap things up and do a great
job with the finale that goes a really
long way in my book yeah
cool all right so i think that does it
for this episode of the stronger by
science podcast as always thank you so
much for joining us and we will be back
soon with another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you you could sign up for the free
newsletter at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you